so to be considered a promotion designer
you have to really give your project a
final polish is what I call it and
that's where you add some final
finishing touches to your project to
really push it over the edge and really
make it look Pro well in today's video
podcasts we're gonna talk about two
things you can do to polish your motion
design
[Music]
hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
and today we're talking about polish
that's what I call it
it's some people call finishing I've
heard polish around the block but I've
always called it Polish polish to me is
when you've got your project 80% there
90% there maybe 75% there and you need
to take it to the next level
ok and that's what polish is and there's
there's several different techniques you
can do to finish off a piece I teach a
lot of this and style craft and a little
bit of it in pro flows plus but what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna
polish off this piece ok so what I've
got here is I've just got a space
background image here I've got a
particle system from trapcode particular
it's just flying at us and essentially
this is supposed to look like these
really fast particles flying past the
camera in space like maybe it's space
debris from a comet or something but as
flies past us really quickly and right
now it looks ok I wouldn't even say it
looks great you're just good it just
looks ok right so if I slow it down you
can see here we've got a camera we've
got our particle system and we've got a
background image the camera is just
slightly pushing in which is why you can
see when we get to the very end here
there's a jump back just right there so
the particles like I said there's a
couple of particle systems happening in
this one instance of trapcode particular
some different colors and greens and
blues and whites that that helps to add
to the realism once we polish this off
okay so like I said right now it doesn't
look so hot but there's two things we
can do the first thing we can do is we
can add motion blur to our particle
systems now you know if you're just
animating systems inside of After
Effects like animating layers and things
like that all you have to do is
literally come down here and turn on
motion blur you click this button here
and boom there it is you want to make
sure it's turned on here as well but
inside of trapcode particular
sometimes you have to come down here
into the rendering
and you have to make sure that motion
blur is turned on for the comp settings
I don't remember if it's default off or
if it's on or comp settings but I have
it set to comp settings which is right
here okay so again if I turn off motion
blur that's how it did look with it
turned on it looks a lot more
interesting so if I preview this you're
gonna see all of a sudden just really
quick let me play it one more time
without motion blur and here is with
motion blur so there we go there is with
motion blur it's already night and day
difference this reminds me of like a
Star Wars you know light light speed
tunnel something like that so it's night
and day between no motion blur and
motion blur right just one very simple
application one very simple technique of
just turning motion blur on and it looks
like this so the other thing we're gonna
do though is we are going to pause it
right here and we're going to open up
our camera and we're just going to turn
on depth of field I've set up some
aperture and focus distance ahead of
time just to give it a little bit of
depth where I wanted to look I'm going
to turn it on and wow look at that right
look at that that is awesome looking
that completely changes it so now looks
like we have a lot of depth in our image
we've got the background as all of a
sudden it's out of focus so there's no
depth of field there's depth of field
all right so we've got motion blur
turned on at depth of field turned on
and let's preview this and there we go
that is with depth of field turned on so
now we've got motion blur and depth of
field added to our very simple particle
systems and you can see what a
difference what a Polish this makes on
top of our particle systems that's what
I got for you in today's video podcast
as always I hope you learned something
always think about applying motion blur
and camera depth of field if you are
using a camera if you're not using a
camera there's also other ways you can
add depth of field to really add some
dimension
to your motion design until next time
I'm Cameron and this is motion science
SIA
[Music]
you